all right well you've had um some nude
scenes so why bring this up is I often
wonder for actors like what does your
mama like is she like watching it or oh
I just want to say my mom said no one
would recognize me with my clothes on
and I just want to say I feel like
people recognize me when I walked out a
little bit but um yeah my mom you know
my mom's the coolest she says I have the
cutest butt yeah
I should show it off yeah you know I
like that I gotta show it off while I
can I can't give this away
I just love I always wonder I'm like I
it doesn't ever bother me but I'm like
my mother like the things that come out
of my mouth bother my mother so much so
yeah I'm just very open and she's not as
much and so yeah she's like how did my
daughters come out of me so I always
wonder like how because we're both like
me and I just always wonder like what
they do when they see you on screen if
they're just like this or if they're
just fast forward or if they're like
skip in general I didn't she watches it
she watches it I didn't tell her my boss
was in the white house I didn't tell her
feel like you didn't tell her and she
found out that way or yeah yeah okay
yeah she's just like you know I wish I
had a little bit of a heads up but like
cute ass
babe she's super supportive for you to
be pooping in the suitcase or what ended
up happening
I think uh I think she was like you know
what you're gonna you made your moment
and that suitcase or show your ass and
you did it you did it babe okay no segue
there
[Music]
[Applause]
hungry
[Music]